ha ha ha Z going read my his pair out of
pack we're back in n Orlando I played a
little bit with algebra I'm sorry
so today we're gonna conquer or Stein
and smog which a lot of you brothers are
saying it's like one of them was
annoying bosses in the game there they
are
it can't be that bad
nice balls so these are called Pikachu
NS Snorlax for a reason huh
oh so the fat guy is little slower so if
I keep moving now never might never
might never mind
Oh goddamn oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] intense
man now I really like the boss fight
it's cool what that's so unfair no worse
in Trevor no no no oh oh oh oh my god
No why does he ever [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] I have to have a fat ass friend
who will beat your ass
boom
all right here we go okay okay god damn
it
God don't don't tell me I died
doesn't matter how well you do on this
[ __ ] boss you make one tiny tiny
little mistake and you are out all right
we can do this hit him a few times or
not a single time how about that you
fact ain't ugly okay I'm gonna try to
[ __ ] nuke that little [ __ ]
there we go that's what I wanted oh you
think you're Daffy baby okay you are
pretty [ __ ] tough
there it is you're [ __ ] that now oh
holy [ __ ] on a stick and I get OH
why aren't you dad okay I don't know
what to do
what do I know he's [ __ ] dead that
slope Oh God what is he doing any armor
that has nipples is a great armor okay
we're gonna take this slower than a
[ __ ] tarantulas ass oh holy [ __ ] that
damage Oh God that's not bad
take that spawn of Satan hey that's
pokeball night jab la Fitte look how
little damage I then
where am I
killed by a guys crotch squished by a
guys crotch that's a nice way to die put
that on my gravestone if I ever die that
way I guess come on
how do you do me what what happened
didn't I die then I died I died what is
happening I'm I swear to god I'm dead oh
come on
thanks appreciate it bravo Bravo Pitts
come on oh god Jim [ __ ] this [ __ ] come
on you have to dodge every [ __ ]
attack come on
Oh watch really
you missed the giant ass in the giant
ass take that okay it's it's fine really
I don't even care it's not a big deal
it's just a game anyway
I have a pretty decent idea to kill a
lunch sign Sam out is gonna be a proud
bill and get it what is he doing hugging
him I know it I know it was - were up to
something unchristian did I get him did
I get him I got him
whoo there's a chance and one of a
million goddamn he looks like a [ __ ]
frog with Ted's
seriously I feel like I found a way to
exploit him pick a choke Oh
I choose you
oh don't [ __ ] up did you give completed
harder task in your live pads whoo my
[ __ ] kid and I haven't it's wait for
your moment don't be greedy
now sit now's my chance now it's my
chance now it's my chance this game is
like a drug was he experienced at first
[ __ ] happiness of completing a boss
you just want you need more I just got
my fix right there okay be gentle with
me I know you hate me
oh is that Bob on fire don't know what
do we got in here kneel before their
boobs
hope you brothers had a great Christmas
and I hope you enjoyed this video leave
a like if you did I really appreciate it
as always hit subscribe to come abroad
today and the brofist to ya